hi everybody it's monday
[Music]
gosh i love mondays hi
everybody welcome to the show there is
so much to talk about today
there are so many stories to cover you
know andy cohen actually
said to me you are a walking mood board
and to that i said
yeah accurate and when i thought about
the show we were going to make today
it felt like a mood board we want to
talk about ruth bader ginsburg
we have ross matthews here to discuss
last night's emmys
we have jose andres here to speak
about the life-changing good that can be
done
in the world of food we have paris
hilton
who is in a different place in her life
and she's opening up to us
about all of it and i am truly able to
connect with her about something very
unique that we both share
so hello vffs
hi to you at home thanks for being with
us
we're going to get right into our news
and we're going to do it in
our style serving at sunnyside up it's
time
for drew's news
[Applause]
excuse me sir ma'am guy
tell me your story
ma'am i asked you a question
this is drew's news
this is true's news it's drew's news
hi well we're gonna get right into it
because for the first time
ever at home prime time emmys was last
night so
we gotta do about last night emmy's
edition
all right oh i love the uh paparazzi
sound effect here to help us is emmy
winner himself the lovable and
effervescent even at 6am l.a time ross
matthews hello ross
hi ross i love when you stepped into all
of our lives
with uh jay leno and you've really just
been someone that every time we see
you're smart you're funny we love your
take on everything
you make the world a better place oh
yeah i just wake up at 5am every morning
for you here in l.a if you're gonna talk
like that
ross i will always make it worth your
while and have you slept because you won
a third emmy last night
[Applause]
we won again let me tell you look at
that it is
unbelievable you know i love award
seasons they're like my christmas my
easter my thanksgiving
ever since i was a little kid my mom
bought me an old red towel at a thrift
store we put it on the front porch
and i used to pose on it and pretend i
was on the red carpet and no
drew look at life i love that
well illuminate us with all of your
wisdom
we have to talk about shit's creek i
mean they uh schwepped
i mean every category they won
everything and just when you were about
to kind of be like
all right spread it out share the love
the levees would come and do these
speeches that were so
gracious and incredible you're like you
know what you just take everything you
go right ahead have it all
well you know listen people kind of
heard of this show
it got some big emmy nominations last
year and i think in quarantine it was
like the perfect show to binge
and that also happened to be when
everyone was voting on awards
and that party the fact that they were
all together i kind of you know was so
happy for him but also like can anyone
get an appetizer around here
every two seconds they've got to stand
up and make a speech but it really was
so great to see this little show that
could with comedy legends
yeah winning a historic seven all big
all of seven categories
i also think that like when it's a last
season
you know it's like we want to celebrate
your entire board
vision of legacy that you've left in the
entire show
so it well done oh listen i love remy
yousaf he had like
jeff's piccoli attire which is something
i totally relate to
and then he put this out on social which
i thought was hilarious this is what
happens
when you don't win the emmy and the guy
in the hazmat
suit just has to kind of you know walk
away
because they were delivering all the
enemies just like this you know like
uber eats this was uber emmys
their houses but i mean please don't
take it away can you just wait in the
car if i'm not going to win i don't want
to see it
it was like this is how you lose the
emmys in 2020.
uh wait we have to talk about zendaya
who is
just one of my favorite people on planet
earth for every reason
in the world and her win was
history last night or her story as we're
saying now
yeah i finally got that one um
it took me a minute to learn her story
uh but i
she's the youngest person ever to win
lead drama
24 years old she is the youngest she's
only the second african-american woman
after viola davis now listen
the previous youngest winner was jody
comer last year who was 26 one for
killing eve
oh what i loved in zendaya's speech is
that she talked about the young people
in the streets right now thanking them
for keep fighting
and just looking at her with that emmy
virtually at home it was just such a 20
20 moment
like such a time capsule and her not to
be
shallow but her fashion couldn't have
been more on point she
is a walking mood board of sort of how
one can express themselves and
i just think she's so deserving and such
an inspiration
for uh the next generation
and then i'm just gonna end it on i have
to go out on the laugh
alex borstein i was like wait what is
going on here
why is she doing this but i was so into
it i'm like i like weird and she really
gave it up
let me tell you something she is hashtag
mood for all of us right now it's like
all i want to do is be in like a silk
robe
and some champagne laying on a chase
lounge can i just live like that life
i just thought thank you you gave me
some eye candy
and this was sort of odd and the whole
thing was very unique and interesting
and i don't know where we go from here
but i appreciated what jimmy kimmel and
everybody did last night and i thank you
for being here to recap what's happening
with the
emmys 2020 and congratulations
thank you so much it was so great to
have the enemies last night the world
feels like crazy and it felt like a
little piece of almost normal last night
that's why we got right into it today so
thank you for helping us i love you and
please come back asap
i promise i will thank you
[Music]
you